Рік пандемії COVID-19 для багатьох став роком економічних втрат, безробіття та безгрошів'я.
Однак є і ті, хто зміг скористатися ситуацією та вийти з кризи, яка все ще триває, переможцем.
Так, у часи обмеження контактів між людьми особливо добре йдеться службам доставки.
Електронну комерцію теж в один голос називають переможцем пандемії.
Ще до пандемії онлайн-гігант Amazon мав рекордні обороти, але і їх вдалося суттєво збільшити.
Хто у виграші після майже року пандемії в Україні?
В умовах пандемії роздрібна торгівля стала значним рушієм і для української економіки, відзначають у Мінекономіки.
Загалом у перші 11 місяців 2020 року її обороти зросли на 8 відсотків - до 38 мільярдів доларів.
Щодо продажів онлайн, то цей сегмент виріс непропорційно сильно.
Так, якщо у попередні роки частка онлайн-продажів гіпермаркетів становила лише кілька відсотків, то в часи локдауну вона зросла до 20 відсотків.
Вагома частка онлайн-продажів відбувалась, зокрема, через рітейлер Rozetka.
Компанія хоча й не називає абсолютних цифр своїх доходів, але каже, що суми щомісячних замовлень збільшились.
Удвічі-утричі зросли продажі товарів особистої гігієни, побутової хімії, медичних приладів.
Електроніку й побутову техніку люди добре купували онлайн і у 2019 році, у 2020-му замовлень через інтернет стало ще більше.
У середньому від початку карантину навесні на електроніку витрачали на 17 відсотків більше, на товари категорії "мода та стиль" - на 22 відсотки.
Зиск від онлайн-буму мали насамперед уже відомі онлайн-майданчики -
мобільного зв'язку Allo, парфюмерно-косметичний Makeup, електроніки Foxtrott.
Сплеск онлайн-продажів позитивно вплинув і на служби доставки.
Зокрема, "Нова пошта" у першому півріччі 2020-го доставила 128 мільйонів посилок та вантажів.
Це на третину більше за аналогічний період попереднього року.
Удвічі зросла і активність міжнародної доставки "Нова пошта Глобал" - до 2,5 мільйонів вантажів.
Поки інші підприємства скорочували персонал, компанія відкривала нові філії та шукала тисячі додаткових співробітників.
Зміцнили свої позиції завдяки "ковіду" також державна "Укрпошта" та служби кур'єрських послуг.
Відвідини ресторанів тривалий час були обмеженими або зовсім забороненими.
Багато людей замовляли доставку готової їжі. Тому у пандемію особливо успішними були сервіси з продажу їжі.
Зокрема, Glovo та UberEats та Raketa. За оцінками, доходи кур'єрських сервісів зросли щонайменше на 50 відсотків.
Ще більше зросла доставка із профільних супермаркетів.
Чи не найбільше від пандемії у світі виграли виробники фармацевтичної та гігієнічної продукції.
Виробництво тестів на коронавірус, масок та засобів лікування ковіду мало би сприяти й українській фармацевтиці й медицині.
Але особливими перемогами тут не хизуються.
Лідер ринку - концерн "Фармак" - заявив, що лише "вийде на планові показники року".
Онлайн-аптеки та доставка ліків офіційно запрацювали в Україні з 14 жовтня 2020-го. Доти аптеки не мали права організовувати доставку.
Деякі бізнеси все ж знаходили лазівки і функціонували.
Але саме завдяки пандемії та карантинам уряд дозволив відтепер торгувати ліками онлайн легально.
Почасти закриті кордони та обмеження міжнародного туризму впродовж усього 2020-го, а особливо влітку, активізувала подорожі всередині України.
Щоправда, офіційної статистики щодо кількості українців, які подорожували в межах країни, немає,
адже більшість організовують свої мандрівки самостійно, не користуючись послугами туроператорів.
Принаймні за даними мобільних операторів, влітку на українських південних курортах значно побільшало абонентів у порівнянні з попереднім роком.
На третину більше туристів, вочевидь,  було на узбережжі Чорного моря.
На Азовському морі відпочивальників було на 55% більше.
Щоправда, такий тренд не втримається, коли подорожі за кордон знову стануть доступними, прогнозують експерти.
Водночас, як стверджують у Держагентстві з туризму, українська економіка недоотримала через зменшення попиту на туризм близько 1 мільярда доларів.
Спортзали відкривають і закривають, а онлайн-курси завжди доступні.
Любителі йоги й фітнесу могли тренуватися вдома і купували абонементи.
До ковідних трендів можна записати й пожвавлення ринку онлайн-освіти.
Зокрема, дистанційні мовні курси.
Хоча поки оборот цієї сфери в Україні оцінюється у скромні 100 мільйонів доларів.